this is the previous end game what
happened who lost it
no they're lost
98 actually was not the best move so
because they could have saved the game
instead of C5
but instead of Knight d8 matter for
check because we had to stop C4 King D4
and now H5 C4 exchange and then he
cannot take because H3 so that's why and
that's unsensitive that was at least you
don't play C4 then just we easily win
tonight at four
yeah yes it seemed to me like the end
game turned around John playing racks
just simply out played racks no the move
D5 was incredible like that was really
high skill
I think the end game was fine for black
so I think is this probably was equal
but it was very sharp because white
white could have run to the spawn but
together between D5
C4 or B4 I don't know which order after
after Rook B it takes six takes and then
you go C4
c4b4
B4 okay B5
no no wait where where's my King James
sorry sorry
what you're seeing here is really really
competitive of the males disgusting
opposition and not giving it up it's my
carcass no it's mine